all right listen I am not here to sing
the Praises of Mark Zuckerberg but I
have to tell you that I am delighted by
what is going on with meta's recently
launched Twitter competitor called
threads I joined threads last night you
can
um you can see my profile there I am
david.pakman on threads and I would love
for you to follow me what is this what
is this all about axios has a good
article explaining it meta's Twitter
competitor for quote friendly
conversation launches early Elon musk's
blunders with Twitter are gifting Mark
Zuckerberg an opportune opening for a
new rival app
threads launched last night at 7 pm
Eastern they were going to debut it
today Thursday but they ended up
debuting it early it's available on
Android and the Apple Store I don't know
what it's called now the iTunes Store I
don't know anything about iPhones I'm
sorry but it's on uh it's available on
Android and Apple phones that's for sure
um a bunch of things that Elon Musk has
done recently have particularly set up
the environment for some kind of Twitter
competitor there was this rate limit
where if you were not verified on
Twitter if you're not paying for Twitter
you can only see 600 tweets a day it's
pretty Bonker stuff then Twitter
announced that it's tweet deck dashboard
will become available only to paying
subscribers I mean quite frankly Elon
Musk is making blunder after blunder I
know that much like with Jordan Peterson
there are people with Elon Musk that say
David if you think he's making mistakes
it's because you don't understand the
genius of what he's doing I had people
emailing me saying David uh you know
what Elon Musk is doing is actually
genius he's reducing bandwidth costs by
limiting the number of tweets that you
can see and it's all 4D chess and it's
just all completely and totally
incredible all right I just don't seem
to think that's the case my activity on
Twitter is down to almost zero and so is
that of so many of the people that I
follow because it's just become a bad
experience so in comes threads
threads is connected to meta you can log
into threads with your Instagram account
not only am I now on threads the David
packman show is on threads we're looking
at becoming early adopters when it comes
to posting our video content there we're
not exactly yet sure sure whether this
can be automated in some way from a
technical standpoint if anybody happens
to know please let us know we're working
on it and will soon be up to speed Elon
musk's comment on all of this last night
was quote it is infinitely preferable to
be attacked by strangers on Twitter then
indulge in the false happiness of hide
the pain Instagram of course referring
to the idea that threads is seeking to
be a sort of more positive environment
less about trolling and insults and this
sort of thing now what are my real
thoughts about this because as as I'm
sure you know if you know me you know
that I am not about picking the right
billionaire air whose horse I'm going to
attach my buggy to or whatever the case
may be we relying on one possible
sociopath to defeat another is not like
a thrilling and super exciting strategy
for the future of humanity I am not
naive to the undeniable reality that
meta's threads is just another attempt
to monopolize the online discourse
for-profit and control of the narrative
okay I mean like okay so Twitter has
been failing to do it recently so now in
comes Mark Zuckerberg and whatever the
case may be are we all pining for
another corporate controlled platform
not really am I concerned that what
happened on Facebook around recent
elections the spread of disinformation
coveted disinformation election
disinformation it could just take over
threads as well of course I'm concerned
about that of course I'm concerned about
that and unfortunately some of these
decentralized sort of attempts to
replace Twitter have flopped Mastodon
was one uh which I mean listen I got on
there within 10 seconds I knew it was
going nowhere I'm sorry I know people
still email me and say David when are
you getting on Mastodon I'm on it nobody
knows because there's a hundred
different servers and if you're not on
the same server you have no idea I'm on
it I listen I'm sorry I'm sorry okay I
don't think Mastodon is it blue sky I
thought was very interesting I was
concerned that by limiting the number of
new users that could sign up blue sky
was vulnerable to something like threads
coming forward I'm still on blue sky
blue sky now has announced they are
pausing new member signups I mean it's I
I still am holding out hope for blue sky
but it seems as though it's not going
particularly well so on the one hand
I am thrilled that the idea of a more
functional no rate limits no you know
all of this whacked out stuff that's
happening on Twitter I like that I think
that that's a good thing there's a
functional verification system still on
threads because it's using the Instagram
verification system I think that these
things are good on the other hand I can
only imagine that meta's real agenda
here is to continue building this uh uh
environment in which you've got Facebook
and WhatsApp and Instagram and threads
and they're building the metaverse and
on and on and on and meta goes in the
direction of dominating our digital
lives and and taking away autonomy and
potentially hurting democracy so I'm
curious about threads I'm on threads
we're going to start using it as a tool
to promote our content I'm skeptical I
don't know how meta is going to ensure
that threads just doesn't end up with
the exact same misinformation problems
that Facebook and Instagram quite
frankly had around elections and coveted
disinformation so find me on threads at
david.pakman the show is there at David
Pacman show it's actually small enough
still where I'm seeing everybody who's
responding to me so like on Twitter it's
a lost cause it's just totally out of
control on threads I'm actually seeing
everybody so follow me there and we'll
see what we end up doing with it one of
our sponsors is yada the Free banking
app that makes it fun to save money just
like a regular bank account you can
withdraw your money anytime and it's
fully FDIC insured when you keep your
money in a yada bank account you'll have
a shot at winning nightly cash prizes
ranging from two cents to a million
dollars for every 25 dollars in your
account you get one recurring ticket to
the nightly prize drawing so if you
deposit a hundred dollars you get four
tickets every single night without
needing to make any more deposits yada
also offers some great budgeting
features the possibility of early
paydays a debit card that rewards you
with up to 100 cash back and tickets on
every purchase yata members have already
won over 15 million dollars so say
goodbye to the traditional savings
account with the minimal interest rate
Freakonomics have described prize-linked
savings accounts like a no lose Lottery
download the app now start saving for a
chance to win big with yada the app
where savings meets excitement go to
with yada.com Pacman the link is in the
description